we're back with some crazy Disney movie
connections that will totally surprise
you watch until the end to find out
which film turned your favorite Disney
characters into animals so so you just
open the door and tell us what you know
Hans in big hero 6 Prince Hans of the
Southern Isles is the cute guy with
shady intentions who swept Princess Anna
off of her feet in Disney's frozen
he's the youngest of 13 children with
very little claim to the throne so you
have how many brothers twelve older
brothers that is unless he tricks a
young naive princess who doesn't have
much experience with the outside world
into marrying him Hans maid Anna
believed that he cared about her of
course he was just trying to fool her so
he could take the throne Hans never had
any intention of being the noble Prince
she had hoped for
in fact Hans was a total jerk if only
there was someone out there who loved
you it only makes sense that he would be
wanted for his crimes even if it is
across different times and other Disney
movies that's why we're not surprised at
all to find Hans on the wanted billboard
at the police station in Disney's big
hero 6 that's right folks if you look
closely at the billboard behind the
police officer in this scene of big hero
6 you'll see a familiar face we're
pretty sure that's a wanted poster of
Prince Hans alright what did he do this
time this little easter egg is proof
that a bad guy can escape his evil deeds
even in other disney movies
midnight bars disney has made more than
one movie about cute loveable animals in
particular Disney seems to be downright
in love with characters of the canine
persuasion for instance Lady and the
[ __ ] made us fall in love with the
stray dog from the wrong side of the
spaghetti restaurant and in a hundred
and one Dalmatians we fell in love with
a whole pack of the most precious
spotted puppies ever we all sighed when
lady in the [ __ ] shared their iconic
spaghetti dinner under the moonlight
behind the romantic Italian restaurant
and we all breathe a big sigh of relief
when Cruella De Vil did not succeed in
making her soft black-and-white
dalmatian puppy
just sayin Cruella Deville is one of the
scariest Disney villains out there G is
one terrifying lady anyway given
Disney's love for planting little nods
to other classic Disney films or Easter
eggs in each film it only makes sense
that these two dog films would come
together and that's exactly what
happened in the midnight park scene of
101 Dalmatians
you can see the lady in the foreground
of the scene and if you look to the
right you'll see the [ __ ] The Little
Mermaid the Disney Princesses certainly
have a lot in common
they're usually wronged by some powerful
evil trickster and imprisoned against
their will but thankfully they always
have some cute animal sidekicks to help
them out take Cinderella for instance
Cinderella was dealt a really bad hand
she was forced to work as practically a
slave for her evil stepmother and
stepsisters after she lost her father
and after she tasted a little bit of
freedom at the ball where she dances
with the prince
she got locked in a room by her wicked
stepmother she almost missed the chance
to try on the glass slipper that would
change her destiny forever Ariel from
The Little Mermaid also got duped by an
evildoer so it only makes sense that
Disney would put a Cinderella Easter egg
in a Little Mermaid if you watch closely
you'll see that the king and the Grand
Duke from Cinderella are in attendance
at the wedding of Prince Erik and
Vanessa or should we say Ursula in
disguise either Disney got tired of
making new background characters and
decided to recycle a few they had
already made or they put these two
characters in as a week two fans you're
not free to make your own choices
sometimes you feel so you're just
Aladdin it seems you can't watch a
Disney film without stumbling upon a
character from another Disney classic
there are some movies that are literally
bursting with Easter eggs and Disney
references Disney's Aladdin is one of
those films due to Robin Williams
amazing talents as the role of genie the
film is loaded with references and not
all of them are related to Disney
classics but still a handful were thrown
in if you're not watching carefully
you'll miss them for instance there's a
scene in which the Sultan is stacking a
bun
trinkets but Jafar burst into the room
and causes the whole toy Tower to fall
but if you look at the toys closely
you'll see a familiar face in there
that's right
beasts from Disney's Beauty and the
Beast is depicted as a figurine among
the rest of the toys and that's not the
only reference to other Disney movies in
Aladdin when Aladdin tells genie that he
plans to use one of his wishes to set
him free genie thinks he's lying
I'll do it I'll set you free we're sure
genie meant no disrespect to Pinocchio
but we all know what it means when his
nose grows bigger fella in the Hunchback
of Notre Dom there are two classic
Disney films that take place in France
the first is the Hunchback of Notre Dom
it's a tale of a deformed bell ringer
with dreams of being out among the
people of the City of France the second
film is about a girl who loves to read
and finds herself to be pretty bored
with the villagers in her town she
wanders around with her nose in a book
there's a part in the Hunchback of Notre
Dom where Quasimodo is singing about
being out there among the other people
of the town this sweet optimistic
character just wants to walk along the
river like an ordinary person it seems
that Bell and Quasimodo want opposite
things though wants to leave her
provincial life and all Quasimodo wants
is to walk among the people he's lonely
up in his tower
both Bell and Quasimodo want more from
their lives
so of course Disney connected these two
characters in the most subtle of ways in
a hunchback of notre Dom when Quasimodo
singing his heartfelt song out there you
can see Belle walking among the
villagers that quasi is singing about
Hercules and The Lion King
Disney's The Lion King is a story about
power integrity and a silly meerkat who
loves to do the hula this is a story
about royalty nobility and a usurper who
thinks he should be the one to become
the king of Pride Rock Simba had some
pretty big footsteps in which to follow
when he had to take his dad's role as
king he was only a child when his father
was taken from him little did Simba know
that his uncle Scar was responsible for
the Stampede that ended mufasa's life
skaar had planned to end Simba's life as
well thankfully Simba was eventually
able to take his place as the rightful
king of Pride Rock in Disney's Hercules
a young godlike boy with extreme
strength rose up feeling like he doesn't
really belong of course that's because
he's the son of Zeus but he must prove
himself as a hero before he can return
to his godlike status there's a scene
where Hercules is posing for a vase
maker while holding up a sword and
wearing an animal pelts for Lion King
fans it's hard to miss the obvious
reference to one of its iconic
characters in this scene
Hercules is actually posing while
wearing the skin of scar from The Lion
King
Zazu did say that scar would make a
handsome throw rug
[Applause]
Tarzan Tarzan is a story about a boy who
lost his parents while in the jungle he
was just a defenseless baby when a bunch
of jungle gorillas took it upon
themselves to care for him he learned
how to behave like the gorillas who
raised him of course his best friends
were also gorillas and let's just say
they didn't have any human manners of
their own in the movie Tarzan and his
pals come across a camp that has been
set up in the jungle
Tarzan's most sassy friend Turk
discovers an interesting find all the
way out in the jungle it's a tea set
that you just might recognize remember
mrs. Potts and chip from Beauty and the
Beast well they make it appearance in
this camp seen Turk actually uses mrs.
pot and chip during that scene can you
imagine what would have happened if mrs.
Potts and chip had started singing be
our guest to Turk Tarzan and his gorilla
pals they probably would have freaked
out mrs. Potts might not have made it
through a gorilla rampage brought on by
mysterious talking teapots and cubs it
could have changed everything if they
accidentally broke mrs. Potts while
rummaging through the campsite what kind
of primitive beasts are responsible for
this Venus Mulan and lilo and Stitch
lilo is a charismatic girl who likes to
challenge the status quo she befriends
mischievous little creatures who help
her embrace her wild spirit lilo doesn't
seem to fit in with her peers she
doesn't follow the conventional path
that seems awfully familiar where have
we seen that before oh right Mulan was a
girl who didn't follow the normal rules
of being a young girl she was a rebel
she was a fighter and she also had some
strange creatures helping her along the
way Mulan had a troublemaker Guardian
who almost seemed to make things worse
rather than help her achieve her goals
likewise lilo and Stitch got into plenty
of trouble together that's why it's no
surprise that you would see a reference
to Milan in lilo and Stitch if you want
to see this connection to Milan look
closely at the wall in Lilo's room there
you'll see a poster of Mulan in her
horse it only makes sense that lilo
would be inspired by a brave
rule-breaker such as Mulan both of these
young ladies have a knack for causing
trouble
but that's what makes them so unique and
brave Toy Story in Finding Nemo Disney
and Pixar's iconic under the sea tail
Finding Nemo didn't only take place
under the seed in fact a very important
part of the story took place in the
dentist office when Nemo is captured
he's brought to a fish tank in a dentist
office it's in that tank that Nemo forms
important friendships with fish he never
would have known otherwise knowing how
much Disney creators love to put Easter
eggs in their films it seems only
natural that we would find one in
Finding Nemo but to our surprise we
found more than one the first one is
when Darla visits the dentist's office
you can see a view of the waiting room
and if you look closely you'll see a
familiar toy on the ground that toy
would be the famous Buzz Lightyear from
Toy Story but that's not all in that
scene waiting room a little boy is
reading a mr. incredible comic book and
if you look through the plastic bag
during the attempted fish escape scene
you'll see the Pizza Planet track from
Toy Story that Pizza Planet truck has
been in a ton of Disney movies don't
believe us check it out for yourself and
count how many times you can find the
truck and other Disney / Pixar movies
Zootopia Zootopia is a film about
animals living together peacefully in a
sort of ideal utopia predators and prey
live peacefully for the most part
there's a particularly clever nod to
many other Disney films in Zootopia that
had Disney fans giggling its weaselton
duke weaselton
and I ain't talking rabbit and ain't
nothing you can do to make me it's a
part where duke weaselton is selling
bootleg copies of popular movies if you
look at his collection they all have an
animal slant on popular Disney films
he's got everything from pig hero 6 to
wrangled to wreck-it Rhino these are
clear references to big hero 6 tangled
and of course wreck-it Ralph this was a
clever little nod to the Disney films
that came before Zootopia Disney clearly
doesn't shy away from references and
easter eggs in its films it makes for an
exciting quest to find all the
connections between the movies
many fans have worked tirelessly to find
all of these connections have you found
some dizzy movie connections worth
noting if so don't be shy tell us in the
comments below thanks for watching the
themes if you love Disney movies as much
as we do be sure to subscribe to our
channel for the latest Disney news and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up see you next time
[Music]